welcome back to cbs mornings you might
have thought you're over covered but
covet ain't over with us government
health officials are sounding the alarm
about a fast-spreading coronavirus
sub-variant is driving up the covey
cases in some areas now this one is
called ba5 and it accounts for 65
percent of all new cases in this country
ba-5 is more contagious and other
omicron sub-variants even infecting
people who are vaccinated and boosted
yikes dr ashish jaws at the white house
he's the covet 19 response coordinator
he joins us from washington d.c dr
jacques good to see you
good morning gail thanks for having me
back
all right we always like you we always
like it when you come on so let's talk
about this this latest variant
people who are double vaccinated double
boosted are starting to get covered now
for the first time i know you might have
heard i had it the first week of june i
was shocked and so depressed i couldn't
believe that it had happened to me but
here we are why is this happening now
for a lot of people who have who
followed all the rules and are still
getting it with this particular variant
what's going on yeah so there's here's
the thing um ba-5 the sub-variant that
you mentioned incredibly immune invasive
so what we're seeing is people who got
infected in january february march
they're getting re-infected at very very
high rates we are seeing people who are
vaccinated and boosted
also have breakthrough infections the
good news gail is that people who are
boosted and having breakthrough
infections they're not getting
particularly sick so that's the critical
part is that we're still preventing
serious illness in folks
but you got to be vaccinated and boosted
because if you have a breakthrough and
you're not boosted then people are
getting really sick with this
you know what i think the problem is dr
ja from the beginning i think we thought
if we got our vaccines if we got our
boost got our boosters we would not get
this coveted but that certainly is not
the case and i think so in a headway we
have to wrap our brains around that and
i think the messaging i think threw a
lot of people off so if you're getting
infected once twice three times a lady
does it mean that it weakens your system
and and makes you more susceptible to
long covet
well so here's what we know i mean
obviously if you have breakthrough
infections have you been vaccinated and
boosted you're much less likely to get
long covered than if you're not
vaccinated and boosted so that's one
point um what when we are seeing
breakthrough infections we're seeing
re-infections as i said um each time you
get infected so far gail it looks like
the next one is less severe so that's
also good news
that said these reinfections can still
be pretty nasty and so what i'm saying
to folks is if you got infected in the
past do not assume that you're going to
be immune going forward and the best way
to protect yourself is just being up to
date on vaccinations making sure that
you've gotten vaccinated at least in the
last six months
dr john back in april the cdc reported
that most americans have had covet at
this point i'm sure the numbers have
increased since then uh eventually i
remember seeing headlines we're all
going to get it uh so give with that in
mind and all these treatments we have in
the vaccines where are we in the course
of this pandemic is it endemic is it a
new normal how would you describe it
yeah it's a great question so the way i
look at it is certainly we're in a way
better position than where we were a
couple years ago right so if you think
back to like 18 months ago when this
president took office and where we were
versus where we are today uh my gosh
we're in so much better place the
problem of why i don't think this is
like endemic or the new normal still
have 300 americans dying every day 300
to 400 americans that's a lot of people
still getting very very sick and dying
we've got to drive those numbers lower
the best way to do it be up to date on
your vaccines get treated if you get
infected that combination really keeps
people out of the hospital and prevents
them from getting very sick so keep here
go ahead so i was gonna say so should
people
you know with these cases rising should
everyone be allowed to get a second
booster now
well so in my mind everyone over 50 if
you have not gotten a shot this year if
it's been six months or longer you gotta
go out there and get that shot that to
me is a no-brainer um for people under
50 you know fda is looking at this topic
right now and trying to sort out whether
they're going to open that up and
they're going to have a decision on that
relatively soon
all right dr shisha we appreciate you
walking us through it thank you very
much come back soon